après l'éclatante victoire des croates
sur l'allemagne hier soir les futurs
adversaires de la france en demi-finale
ont regagné en héros leur base à vittel
alors que zagreb a fêté toute la nuit
cette victoire historique et invité de
ce journal l'entraîneur de l'équipe
croate miroslav blasé l'ugtg qui parle
très bien notre langue
la floride espère des orages pour venir
à bout des incendies qui ont décimé près
de deux cent mille hectares ce matin on
priait dans les églises en implorant le
ciel
lionel jospin a invité du club de la
presse de repas firme ça va mieux bilan
positif de son gouvernement une
politique lisible dit il les 90 ans du
comte de paris dans son château
d'amboise le gâteau du gotha de
l'aristocratie photos de famille et et
feu renaissance madame monsieur bonsoir
après la victoire édifiante décroître
hier soir à lyon
le retour en héros tout à l'heure des
joueurs à vittel depuis près d'un mois
maintenant les footballeurs croates ont
élu domicile dans la ville même mais les
habitants n'ont pas attendu le triomphe
contre l'allemagne pour les adopter
florent gautreau et philippe deslandes
ça ressemble un gendarme à saint tropez
mais ce n'est ni galabru ni saint tropez
c'est miroslav lazovic à l'aéroport
d'epinal mirecourt les croates en
vadrouille profite pleinement de leur
statut de gloire naissante insensible à
la fatigue
il savoure minute après minute les
retombées de leur exploit lyonnais
on en oublierait presque qu'il ya une
demi-finale à jouer dans trois jours la
ligne bleue des vosges se fait rouge et
blanche
vittel par le croate alors le joueur se
met en quatre
après une heure d'avion 30 minutes de
bus les voilà partis pour tester un
autre transport en commun le petit train
touristique qui va faire le tour de la
ville
on a connu des préparations plus
scientifique à quelques heures d'un
match capital mais on a rarement vu des
champions aussi sympathique
c'est un grand moment être reçu comme ça
alors que nous sommes un pays très
récent et que c'est notre premier
mondial
c'est vraiment géant la grande rue de
vittel c'est leur champs elysées a eu le
sentier de leur gloire
ils n'ont pas gagné la coupe du monde
mais c'est tout comme ils ont déjà gagné
l'estiment d'une région en même temps
que la reconnaissance de leur talent un
millier d'admirateurs les attendaient à
leur hôtel au beau milieu du parc de la
ville d'auch le havre de tranquillité
s'est vite transformé en forteresse
assiégée l'espace de quelques heures
vite elle s'est mise au champagne
ivres de bonheur joueurs entraîneurs et
supporters ne pouvait plus quitter match
ces messieurs il m'a dit les résultats
tabac se méfier non je crois pour la
france
pour le moment il m'a dit encore
- ici tout le monde soutient la croatie
ou moins jusqu'à mercredi
mais revenons maintenant à ce match qui
opposait donc hier soir la croatie à
l'allemagne une victoire historique qui
aurait pu imaginer que l'équipe croate
qui faisait figure d outsider puis
s'humilier l'allemagne plusieurs fois
championne du monde
une revanche à un savoir jouer le sang
froid de onze joueurs soudés par une
même ferveur nationale francis maroteaux
avec quatre millions et demi d'habitants
la croatie est le plus petit pays
qualifiés pour la coupe du monde
mais le football est la croatie c'est
une affaire de coeur qui bat au rythme
de ses joueurs d'avoir su coeur 33 but
pour l'attaquant du real madrid est un
énorme avantage il a peu joué cette
saison il est en forme
le maillot croître c'est sa revanche son
compère la taxe et vlahovic le miraculé
opéré du cerveau
aujourd'hui ils forment un duo dangereux
pour desailly blanc thuram et lizarazu
car ils profitent pleinement du travail
opéré par les surdoué du milieu ainsi
boban le milanais peu en forme
actuellement mais tellement doué soldes
ou le joueur de stuttgart l'empêcheur de
tourner en rouge hasanovic surnommé le
professeur de ballons et surtout capable
d'offrir des balles comme celle ci des
ballons que l'on retrouve en quelques
secondes dans la surface adverse pour
deschamps et les siens
il faut briser cette loi du milieu
maîtriser les pourvoyeurs de ballons
d'autant que la bande des quatre est
complété par mario stanic à la fois
défenseur et contre-attaquant stanic qui
offre des solutions et des ballons de
but même à ses défenseurs
désormais fabien barthez c'est qu'une
frappe d'arrière prend une tout autre
résonance des arrières qui mesurent en
moyenne à m 85 et qui érige un mur
devant ladite ch le gardien on le dit
instable avec tendance à passer parfois
au travers face à l'allemagne
il la joue intraitable à l'expérience et
aux réflexes et tous ces joueurs que 7 à
maître à penser
miroslav blasé vite l'ancien entraîneur
de nantes l'actuel entraîneur du plus
petit pays qualifiés mais cela pour le
sait déjà
nou lé intervieweront dans quelques
instants mais d'abord l'entraîneur de
l'équipe de france pour lui la surprise
n'est pas totale aimé jacquet qui avait
vu déjà joué les crois tu avais plus
jugé jauger leur puissance
aimé jacquet qui commentent qui évalue
l'adversaire de la france pour la
demi-finale mercredi prochain au stade
de france
déjà à l'euro j'avais dit la croix aussi
est une équipe extrêmement dangereuse un
jour ou l'autre elle sera dans la finale
et bien je me suis pas trompé
malheureusement elles sont contre ils
sont contre nous mais c'est la loi du
sport j'espère que mercredi et ben nous
nous ferons un grand match de football
monsieur l'algérie camille une formation
extrêmement compétents compétitive avec
un bloc défensif de très grande qualité
avec une réflexion tactique de très haut
niveau mais c'est surtout c'est ses
animateurs etc et ses attaquants qui
sont très dangereux et qui sont je
dirais extrêmement percutant qui est
indiscutablement nous interpelle
aujourd'hui si vous passez mais pour
finir pays bas au brésil non mais
d'abord la croatie ni monsieur blasé
vite je le connais bien nous a préparé
quelque chose et nous allons tous les
deux mercredis à souffrir sur le banc de
touche il nous retrouvons maintenant
direct de vittel l'entraîneur de
l'équipe croate miroslav blazevic
bonsoir d'avoir un mot sur votre état
d'esprit après cette incontestable
victoire 24 heures après la fièvre est
retombée où vous êtes déjà entré dans la
phase de préparation
on était toujours les magazines et ou
folie qui était logique après ses
victoires qui était le monde il a il a
attendu
non malheureusement notre métier il est
vraiment délicat il dément que des
confirmations
la fête s'est arrêté à tout à l'heure
est on prêt on commence notre
préparation d'abord on a eu déjà un
petit entraînement pour dégager toutes
les toxines accumulées et demain on
cherche déjà donné il pousse sur toutes
les capacités nécessaires
j'espère que mes joueurs et de le
récupère complètement
pour mercredi pour cette grande
rencontre de football grands événements
en tout cas pour nous raconter une
équipe avec une tradition qui on en a
pas malgré tout on a quand même quelques
chances également l'aï aimé jacquet
vienne ne t on entendu les capacités de
vos joueurs qu est ce que vous vous
redoutez le plus chez les français
d'abord je prétend connaître bien et qui
peut français et pour moi et qui précède
et première candidats et priant favori
de ces coupes mondiales
si on constate tout simplement que cette
équipe est composée par que plus grands
joueurs européens
l'épreuve est bien vite vu il joue dans
plus grande coupe d'europe j'ai connais
bien personnellement il s'agit d'une
équipe qui est parfaitement bien soudée
mon ami monsieur jacquet mon collègue
malheureusement il n'est pas mis non je
dis ça facilement qui est le véritable
gentleman qui a donné toutes les
compliments à notre équipe
il a bien été parfaitement respectée
première tracteur avant qu'il se décider
pour une conception
ça veut dire il a adapté son style dg au
profil des joueurs qui possèdent et je
suis très objective et je ne pouvais pas
être subjective
non je sais que la france est favori
mais n'oublions pas que les allemands
étaient les favoris je prétends que
logiquement nous ont eu davantage nos ce
match malgré tout il reste très ouvert
qu'est ce qui vous a poussé qu'est-ce
qui vous donnent des ailes est ce que
c'est l'élan la ferveur la fierté
nationale part de madame n'est pas d'un
complet qu'est-ce qui vous déjà compris
j'ai compris fierté nationale je pense
qu'elle possède
chaque jr qui défendent sont payés dans
cette manifestation comme sa grand
commune
championnat demande je ne vois pas in
avantage particulière c'est vrai que
nous sommes conscients de notre
infériorité par rapport d'être favoris
favoris traditionnels qui appartient en
france également parce que nous ne
possédons pas la tradition on sait qu'il
faut être en tout cas 10% super fière
équipe qui a la tradition et ça c'est
une autre avantage non comme sont
conscients on fait tout leur possible
pour récompenser ses désavantages merci
monsieur bhl et d'éviter d'avoir répondu
à nos questions
on peut facilement imaginer l'euphorie
le délire hier soir dans les rues de
zagreb et dans toutes les villes de
croatie une nuit presque blanche pour
cette victoire historique aujourd'hui
personne ne doute que l'équipe croate
ira en finale
laurent boussier josé boulesteix
tonnerre de joie hurlements de victoire
quelques instants après la fin du match
et zagreb sombrer dans la fête
des dizaines de milliers de croates en
hiver une revanche éclatante contre
l'allemagne
une nuit de folie et ce matin une ville
déserte et y chercher son souffle comme
après un excès de bonne heure en milieu
de journée la place centrale de la
capitale croate avait retrouvé son
visage habituel mais les signes de
victoire n'avait pas disparu des
vendeuses de magasins aux enfants en
passant par de nombreux adultes le
maillot fétiche de l'équipe nationale
était partout visibles et les
témoignages recueillis dans les rues
tous unanimes tout le monde sous-estimer
là on a montré notre force tout le
peuple était derrière les joueurs nous
on savait qu'on allait gagner
c'était incroyable avant je pensais que
je pouvais gagner qu'on allons au
penalty maintenant je sais qu'on peut
battre tout le monde et combattre à la
france on va battre la phrase 3 0 est en
finale on battra le brésil 2 0 pour
quelques-uns ou quelques-unes la joie
est tempérée et les croates
il est allemand alors cet après midi
pour ne pas parler de choses qui fâchent
ils ont regardé ivanisevic à la
télévision mais pour mon ami c'était
plus difficile
la presse croate évidemment est à
l'unisson de ses chants de victoire il
faut dire qu'ici plus qu'ailleurs le
foot n'est pas simplement un sport c'est
un outil politique indépendante depuis
1992 la croatie était encore en guerre
il ya trois ans cette victoire de son
équipe de foot va donc peut-être un peu
étancher sa soif de reconnaissance
internationale en allemagne maintenant à
l'image des supporteurs la presse parle
de déception critique la faiblesse du
jeu allemand
et bien sûr évoque la colère contre
l'arbitré a exclu la 40e minute
christian veurne ce tout un pays sonné
après la cuisante défaite infligée par
l'équipe croate réaction à berlin mais
lisez lerner il était de tout coeur
derrière lui
qui paie pensez bien passer une agréable
soirée les cruches de 2 litres de bière
des filets certains crier victoire avant
même le coup d'envoi mais les premières
sueurs froides sont arrivés avec
l'expulsion de la guerre central
allemand
un tremblement de verre sur le bar
angoisse cauchemar des primes
les visages se sont décomposées
progressivement fair-play certains
supporters allemands applaudissent la
croatie après le premier big dans ce bar
les serveurs sont originaires de zagreb
ils passent et repassent les bras levé
devant leurs clients allemands me disais
bouche bée devant le culot de croître
regardez bien ce gardien de but allemand
il va encore surprendre 2 bien que le
bonheur des uns ne fait pas toujours le
malheur des autres
certains compense comme ils peuvent
d'autres continuent à espérer jusqu'au
bout mais ça fera 3 0 c'est ce qu'on
appelle une piquette
les croates ont mérité cette victoire
mais pour moi cet affreux j'ai le cafard
il ne faut pas avoir honte on s'en va la
tête haute ils sont repartis avec des
maux de tête effroyable mais n'ont pas
manqué ce geste remarquable de
fraternité il est vrai qu'elle ment et
croates ou toujours été bon dance
certains avaient l'habitude de dire le
football est un jeu simple un ballon 22
joueurs un arbitre et c'est toujours
l'allemagne qui gagne ça n'est plus vrai
aujourd'hui
voici venue l'heure des comptes ou
plutôt des règlements de compte
la vieille garde doit maintenant
raccrocher les crampons le football
allemand tourner une page de son
histoire en floride désormais tous les
regards se tournent vers le ciel on
priait dans les églises ce matin pour
que des orages tropicaux viennent à bout
des incendies qui ont détruit en cinq
semaines près de 180 mille hectares de
forêt sur place une fumée épaisse
recouvre une partie du nord-est de la
région et les habitants ont trouvé
refuge ici et là dans les hôtels ou chez
l'habitant reportage sur place dominique
derda éric perrin du haut de sa tour ça
fait plus de trente ans que charlotte
guette à l'horizon le moindre signe de
fumée des incendies elle en a déjà vu
mais jamais comme ceux qui depuis six
semaines ravagent tout sa région c'est
trop sec et assécherait ç'a commencé
très tôt cette année mais c'est la
nature on ne peut rien contre la nature
pour lutter contre les flammes des
pompiers sont venus en renfort de
presque tous les états unis ceux ci
arrivent de las vegas au nevada
il allume des contre-feux creusent des
tranchées traces de larges trouées dans
la forêt ils n'iront au contact lance à
la main qu'en dernier recours pour
protéger les maisons de l'autre côté de
la route ce matin le vent souffle vers
l'ouest il est encore faible mais il
pourrait bientôt tourner et souffler en
rafales je suis policier détective en
ville et je me dis que c'est mieux de
rester ici pour défendre ma maison
plutôt que de laisser à d'autres le soin
de faire et puis si elle doit brûler au
moins je serai là pour le voir à
quelques kilomètres de là plus au sud
le feu couve toujours sous la cendre
dans ce village fantôme évacués à la
hâte jeudi dernier les maisons sont
sauvés de justesse
sur les toits de dérisoire petit
tourniquet d'arrosage de pelouse
ils n'ont pas servi à grand chose c'est
grâce au travail des pompiers que demain
les habitants pourront rentrer chez eux
en attendant la police montent la garde
on craint les voleurs presque autant que
les pyromanes
mais on craint surtout le ciel et les
vents de l'atlantique qui chaque
après-midi attise les braises mal
éteinte
voilà pourquoi le feu semble ne jamais
vouloir mourir ce soir pour la seconde
fois en dix jours ils ont plié bagage
comme des milliers d'autres à venteux
prêt à quitter la forêt pour se réfugier
sur la côte a décidé d'attendre ici
parce que si on s'en va on ne pourra
plus revenir
alors j'espère qu'ils parviendront à
contenir l'incendié qu'on pourra rentrer
chez nous d'ici une heure ou deux cet
enfer quotidien c'est à l'église que
beaucoup tentent de trouver la force de
le supporter pompiers habitants évacués
de leurs maisons voisins amis toute une
région implore aujourd'hui la clémence
du ciel et prix main dans la main pour
qu'enfin ton de la pluie
en grèce avec la canicule et les
incendies qui menaçaient le nord
d'athènes depuis hier ont été maîtrisés
en fin d'après midi
plus d'un millier de pompiers à pied
d'oeuvre pour sauver l'un des poumons
verts de la capitale le mont parnès 180
foyers au total ont été classés
apparemment la plupart seraient
maintenant sous contrôle
et puis en italie la vague de chaleur a
fait plusieurs victimes les températures
commencent à baisser les départs de feu
certains d'origine criminelle notamment
en calabre
en france près d'arras dans le pas de
calais à un retraité qui s'était
retranché chez lui depuis le début de la
matinée après avoir légèrement blessé un
voisin était maîtrisé mais gign a pris
position autour de la maison isolée par
un périmètre de sécurité est intervenue
alors qu'un contact avec un psychologue
avait été établie l'homme un ancien
agriculteur avait été interné il ya une
dizaine d'années selon ses voisins
c'était un ancien d'indochine ou un ex
légionnaire politique lionel jospin a
invité du club de la presse de repas
tout à l'heure à résumer l'évolution
économique et politique de la france
depuis son arrivée au pouvoir
avant les français est désorienté
aujourd'hui ça va mieux dit en substance
le premier ministre nous écoutant moi je
pense que les français peuvent se dire
aujourd'hui ça va mieux ça c'est
important ça va mieux si vous regardez
quelle était la situation il y a un an
et demi nos concitoyens étaient
désorientés étaient presque interloqué
par la politique que leur proposaient
les dirigeants d'alors il ne voyait par
le rapport entre ce qu'on leur avait dit
dans la campagne présidentielle et la
politique qui a été conduite au moins
peut-on dire aujourd'hui un an après où
un peu plus d'un an après la prise de
responsabilité par la nouvelle majorité
le gouvernement que je dirige qu' il y a
un rapport entre ce qui a été dit et ce
qui est fait c'est bien la politique qui
a été annoncée qui est conduite
il y a donc une lisibilité de la
politique souvenez vous cette phrase
célèbre de françois mitterrand avec
laquelle j'avais d'ailleurs pris ma
distance
à propos du chômage 10 ans on a tout
essayé et
nous nous avons essayé encore
considérant que c'était possible
enel jospin n'ont porté par les bons
indices de la croissance de la
consommation et le recul du chômage
dresse un satisfecit de la politique
qu'il conduit avec la gauche plurielle
et qui donne des résultats
oui en tout cas il suffit d'écouter le
premier ministre ça va mieux notre
politique va réussir le gouvernement
travaille sérieusement
voilà c'est tout le message que lionel
jospin a martelé tout au long de son
intervention bilan d'un an un matignon
sans faire de triomphalisme en en
rajoutant parfois même dans la prudence
le pragmatisme et sa fameuse modestie le
premier ministre a néanmoins voulu
afficher sa détermination est même sa
fermeté face à sa majorité plurielle qui
tend à verser dans la division lionel
jospin a mis sur le dos du conservatisme
de la classe politique française l'échec
de sa réforme du mode de scrutin aux
élections européennes en revanche son
ton a été beaucoup plus dur à l'égard de
ceux les verts et les communistes qui
soutiennent les sans-papiers et
réclament une régularisation pour tous
nous sommes dans un état de droit a
rappelé le premier ministre
une loi a été votée soupçonné
l'administration qui l'appliquent de
quelques à quelque chose d' insulte
alors l'opposition s'est également faite
temps c'est un exemple parmi d'autres le
plan juppé a été un triple échec
technique financier et juridique et le
gouvernement doit reconstruire un
système de maîtrise des dépenses de
santé
plus généralement lionel jospin reproche
à la droite de s'opposer en toutes
circonstances même sur des projets juste
avec une pique particulière pour
philippe séguin qui je cite ne se
comprend pas lui même
pas de quoi cependant troubler la
sérénité du premier ministre qui se voit
en chef de train celui de la france et
des réformes et circonstances obligent
en footballeurs mélange de jacquet et de
zidane cela toujours en toute modestie
bien sûr si gérard leclerc de son côté
philippe séguin président du rpr dans
son discours de clôture des universités
d'été a estimé que la france perd son
temps sous le gouvernement jospin
une charge contre la politique
rassurantes du premier ministre philippe
séguin par ailleurs annoncé la tenue
d'une convention nationale sur l'europe
pour la rentrée à toulouse
carole comment marie pierre cassignard
ce fut l'un des temps forts de ce
week-end un match amical entre la
direction du rpr et de jeanne du temps
de haute garonne sous l'oeil d'un grand
amateur de football
le rpr aime les symboles il veut
désormais se voir comme une équipe sheed
même si la plupart des grands connor
mais passé le déplacement saint charles
pasqua aura finalement honorer le rendez
vous est fait entendre sa différence sur
l'europe l'europe qui n'en finit plus de
diviser le rpr philippe séguin a donc
annoncé aujourd'hui une convention
nationale déterminera dès la rentrée la
position du mouvement gaulliste sur ce
dossier une manière de préserver la
cohésion du rpr pour encore mieux
s'opposer au gouvernement
la france perd son temps elle perd de sa
substance
elles sont gordy oui mes chers
compagnons cette modestie
cette fameuse modestie avec des par le
gouvernement cette autre façon de
gouverner dont on nous rebat les
oreilles
elle n'est une forme nouvelle de la
résignation combativité et unique du
mouvement gaulliste philippe séguin
reste déterminé à poursuivre les
objectifs qu'il s'est fixés le processus
de reconstruction de l'opposition
s'annonce bien long mais à toulouse le
rpr a voulu réaffirmer qu'il était
néanmoins bel et bien engagée à paris
cet après midi dans le quartier de
belleville plusieurs centaines de
personnes en majorité kabyles se sont
retrouvés pour protester contre la loi
généralisant l'utilisation de l'arabe au
milieu de la foule un drapeau algérien
sur lequel était collée un portrait du
chanteur assassiné lounès matoub en
algérie même les autorités avaient
choisi ce 5 juillet pour mettre en
application cette loi sur l'arabisation
désormais l'administration les
entreprises et les médias devront
rédiger en arabe tous leurs documents
autant d'obligations entente symbole qui
provoque de vives réactions notamment
dans la communauté kabyle
cet après midi dans le centre d'alger
une marche de plusieurs centaines de
personnes pour protester contre cet ex
les ions linguistique thierry thulliez
bruno girodon assister à une
manifestation en algérie c'est
aujourd'hui à coup sûr entendre des
slogans hostiles au pouvoir de ce qu'on
osait à peine dire publiquement il ya
peu encore cet après midi c'est l'autre
parti d'opposition le front des forces
socialistes qui a tenté de mobiliser ses
militants
quelques centaines d'entre eux ont
réussi à braver l'interdiction de la
marche
il leur a fallu passer entre les mailles
d'un imposant dispositif de sécurité
en démocratie réelle et nous voulons
qu'ils nous la promo jugeant sur pièce
pour cela l'arabisation c'est surtout
l'occasion d'exprimer un ras-le-bol
général
car contrairement la kabylie alger a
vécu tranquillement l'entrée en vigueur
de la nouvelle loi la télévision
publique algérienne s'est depuis
longtemps adapté
la seule nouveauté à partir
d'aujourd'hui c'est le sous titrage en
arabe les films étranges
même parmi les francophones l'usagé
obligatoire de la ram dans les
entreprises et les administrations
n'effraie pas forcément amis de bosser
l'âme est éditeur
la plupart de ses livres sont publiés en
français l'arabisation à ses yeux peut
être une chance quelle passion éditorial
aujourd'hui ce que d'offrir sartre en
arabe
simone de beauvoir camus est beau et de
l'autre et minou et pourquoi pas en
arabe on va s'ouvrir sur le monde
et puis on va être amené maintenant à
traduire ses ouvrages
c'est une bonne chose en soi la
mobilisation particulièrement forte en
kabylie n'a donc pas fait reculer le
pouvoir mais les partis d'opposition
n'entendent pas s'arrêter là en appelant
à d'autres manifestations
il compte bien poursuivre le mouvement
de protestation en irlande du nord près
de belfast la marche des protestants de
l'ordre d'orange s'est déroulée sous
haute sécurité dans la ville de port
d'aden
placé sous contrôle de l'armée la
tension était palpable alors que
quelques milliers d'orange east
défilaient dans le centre de la ville a
arrêté net à mi parcours par des
barbelés pour les empêcher de franchir
le secteur catholique etienne leenhardt
lorsque la tête du cortège des marcheurs
de l'ordre d'orange est arrivé cet après
midi à l'entrée de garda glaude le
comité d'accueil était simple des
dizaines de militaires face aux 5000
protestants qui comme chaque année
souhaitaient emprunter cette rue
traversant un quartier catholique
seule une muraille de fer et de fils
barbelés à renvoyer l'écho de leur
coller une journée spéciale pour une
tournée de célébration de notre culture
partout dans le monde les gens peuvent
le faire nous ne sommes pas différents
des autres
mais dans notre cas on nous l'avait
redit depuis 1807 les orangistes marche
ainsi chaque 5 juillet il fait une
victoire des protestants sur les
catholiques et c'est aussi un moyen pour
eux opposés au récent accord de paix de
démontrer leur force cette année
l'entrée vers gaza guiraude leur est
interdite et sous l'oeil des catholiques
du quartier ils passent donc leur chemin
les catholiques sont minoritaires a
porté dans cette artère est un peu leur
sanctuaire et jusqu'au dernier moment
ils sont restés vigilants
c'est un quartier catholique on ne veut
pas d'orgie leader des filets
triomphaliste dans nos rues sans
incidents finalement les orangistes ont
rebroussé chemin les déterminés se
relaieront sans doute au pied de ce
barrage
eux qui depuis des générations font de
cette marche une question d'honneur même
si elle est hors du temps
ce mur de dunks sera donc désormais le
nouveau symbole des orangistes
protestantes pour la guerre sans fin
qu'il mène afin que l'irlande du nord
restera attaché à la couronne
britannique
quoi qu'il advienne ils promettent
d'être là l'année prochaine et les
années suivantes ce week-end marqué par
les premiers départs en vacances sur les
routes de france les gendarmes ont mis
en place de nombreux dispositifs pour
encadrer et sécuriser les conducteurs
susceptible de s'arrêter sur les aires
de repos les vacanciers souvent
insouciant sont une proie facile pour
les voleurs virginie fils est effective
et ont suivi une patrouille sur
l'autoroute a6 a été cassé
cette découverte fait partie des petites
surprises du matin cette nuit certains
s'en sont pris à l'accès de services
d'une des aires de repos 24 heures sur
24 les gendarmes du peloton autoroutier
de villefranche se relaient au rythme de
cinq patrouilles par jour mission
prioritaire en période estivale
surveiller et sécuriser les aires de
repos on a beaucoup de situations
cocasses la nuit où on trouve beaucoup
de gens qui ont leur voiture chargée qui
dorment par terre en rouler dans les
salles de couchage les portières des
voitures ouvertes soit les plus riants
bars y avait des gens leur faire fermer
les voitures mais ils nous prennent
entre guillemets un peu pour des fous
disent que c'est pas possible pourtant
ça arrive puisque beaucoup de gens se
font casser les voitures du temps
dormant dans les voitures vacanciers
insouciant qui rime avec gendarmes
vigilant chaque été sur l'a6 plusieurs
dizaines de plaintes pour vols sont
enregistrés sur les parkings
la présence accrue des patrouilles
dissuade peut être les uns et rassure
les autres beaucoup de gens qui viennent
parce que racketter en boutique
on a beaucoup de pirelli on a beaucoup
de gens aussi à cette période qui font
des voiles à l'arraché
sur le parking une voiture ouverte à un
moment d'inattention
l'occasion fait le larron dit le dicton
la gendarmerie préfère parler de
délinquance opportuniste on peut pas
dire que nous ayons des bandes
organisées
on n'a pas décelé de tels phénomènes en
tout état de cause
pour ce qui concerne l'année 96 et 97 on
a eu aucune agression physique contre
les personnes sur les heures de repos
ici les pirates de la route n'ont donc
pas sévi quant aux bandits de grand
chemin la maréchaussée continue de
veiller
on ne sait jamais et puis cette nuit
entre toulouse et bayonne un accident
provoqué par un dépassement dangereux
d'une caravane qui tentait de doubler un
car cet accident a fait 13 blessés dont
trois graves
deuxième jour des collections
prêt-à-porter 99 chez lanvin d'abord
élégant structure et décontracté avec
ses vestes longues portées sur de larges
pantalons
on joue sur la transparence c'est
thierry mugler défilé homme que nous
voyons là actuellement détenus et très
estivale et kenzo pour finir le
couturier quant à lui saint-laurent
prépare pour le soir de la finale du
mondial un défi l'extravagant 300
mannequin 130 habilleuse et autant de
techniciens pour une mise en scène
grandiose nicole cornu langlois et
bernard connor ont assisté aux
préparatifs 18 ans alec est l'une des
300 madone de podium qui vont
s'affronter au stade de france 80 mille
spectateurs plus passionné par le foot
que par la mode
impressionnant non c'est pas dit qu'ils
ont péri de la même personne qui revient
de fautes c'est pas du tout bruce c'est
vrai que c'est sur le final furlan
300 paires de chaussures à talons épais
conçu spécialement pour ne pas abîmer la
pelouse ont ainsi envahir le stade avant
la finale pour célébrer les noces
magique de l'élégance et du foot autour
des maquettes dans l'hôtel particulier
d'yves saint laurent se construit le
spectacle nous prévenir en 300 figurants
qui vont être simulé verront pas la
veille en a pas de caméra on a eu cette
idée de recouvrir cette pelouse comme
dans un miroir qui capte les nuages et
donner cette sensation que les
mannequins glisse progressivement sur
scène comme dans un rêve choisi parmi
les quatre modèles du musée du grand
couturier regroupés en cinq continents
chaque tenue illustre une facette du
talent de saint laurent depuis 40 ans
mia mannequin vedette pendant 15 ans
chez lui porte l'ensemble indigo fleuron
du thème des arts inspirés par les
grands peintres du siècle picasso
mondrian ou égard non plus j'ai beaucoup
aimé cette confrontation
des femmes et des hommes de la mode et
dysport du rare et de la rue et qui fait
que c'est ainsi que la vraie poésie et
glisse quand on mélange au jeu des
confrères fini par produire une
étincelle
l'idéal pour lui et tant que le soir de
la finale les deux vainqueurs soit
l'équipe de france et ce alors en tennis
à wimbledon c'est l'américain pete
sampras qui a en cinq sets battu le
croate goran ivanisevic près de trois
heures de route une superbe finale le
numéro 1 mondial remporte pour la
cinquième fois le tournoi robben depuis
laurent jalabert pour la première fois
de sa carrière est champion de france de
cyclisme sur route
âgé de 29 ans jalabert sur le circuit de
charade dans le football a devancé son
compagnon d'échappée et luc leblanc et
le tours d'un circuit pour un tours d'un
circuit très difficile 212 km il servira
un cap et la troisième place dans son
château d'amboise le comte de paris
célébrée aujourd'hui ses 90 ans le gotha
de l'aristocratie ou côtés d'henri de
france entouré de ses enfants et de ses
petits enfants
une photo de famille suivie d'une fête
renaissance que nous raconte ce film et
elle est alain look at you photo de
famille il est dit le comte de paris
prétendant au trône de france
entourée de ses enfants et
petits-enfants
pour célébrer en grande pompe ses 90
printemps
ce qui me touche beaucoup c'est
l'émotion et la junte pour la première
fois le château royal d'amboise
construit par charles gide et françois
1er accueillez festivités et membres du
gotha international
300 invités représentant les familles
royales d'europe
il fallait avoir digéré quelques règles
élémentaires du protocole pour éviter
les impairs risque on dansera ici je ne
pense pas mais pourquoi pas musique
renaissance pas d'heureux on peut danser
le menuet ou vaduz en goguette l'anglais
ans renaissance nous replongeait quatre
siècles en arrière
les familles royales ont parfois la
nostalgie à fleur de peau
par panel de la loire et d'italie suivi
de djénine de touraine façon fonte de
paris farah diba sa droite maria de
russie à sa gauche
le protocole une fois de plus
scrupuleusement respecté éthique à
tobrouk
monseigneur le comte de paris avoue
encore rêver de restaurer la monarchie
si ce n'est pour lui pour son fils ou
son petit fils après tout du team en
politique ce qui compte c'est l'espagne
l'amour et la passion des français pour
la navigation de plaisance cette année
encore ils seront plus de 3 millions à
pratiquer une activité nautique sur les
côtes plus d'un million de bateau
histoire de larguer les amarres et de
respirer un peu de brise marine
retrouvant jean jacques dufour et blaise
grenier qui navigue dans le port de
saint tropez le bateau sur lequel nous
naviguons ce n'est pas un voilier de
course mais le pointu de jean-pierre
jouvenceau simple et rustique beaucoup
moins frime que ça ça c'est un offshore
une cigarette
il y en a plein le port de saint tropez
enfin disons qu'il y en a beaucoup plus
que des pointus ou des patrons pêcheurs
elles seront placées par les yeux tu
sais ça fait l'autre alors bien plus
élaborées par les plusieurs plus mais
c'est surtout de plus en plus gros
diotte à 120 millions de francs au zoo
diack à 14000 ce port est une magnifique
vitrine du marché de la plaisance un
marché qui n'est pas seulement celui des
vanités puisque la filière nautique
française représente quand même trente
mille emplois et 10 milliards de francs
de chiffre d'affaires au balo port ici
fait des recettes de 7 millions bénéfice
au complet à titre indicatif sachez que
pour s'amarrer sur le quai d'honneur là
où on est vu par tout le monde il faut
débourser entre 2000 et 5000 francs par
jour cela dit si vous êtes performant
vous pouvez toujours comme frédéric
naviguer sur le bateau des autres en ce
moment il est à bord d'un soit 56
prototype de la nouvelle série 156 raïs
qui a été entièrement modifiée de son
propriétaire qui souhaitaient avoir à la
fois notre présence avec les critères de
schwann ont malgré tout un bateau de
course ultra performant pour acquérir ce
genre de navire ultra performant
comptait 12 millions de francs
c'est cher mais lazio - vous n'avez pas
à refaire les vernis
et ce genre là ça vous fait quoi vous
qui va être de la voix sont belles
maisons
tenez voilà à quoi ça ressemble une
belle maison flottante
ce bateau tente m c'est un mangusta son
prix 40 millions de francs
vu de là haut ce magnifique rives en
acajou finit par ressembler à un you est
joli bateau
mais c'est la première fois en meeting
si c'est pour moi ces bateaux italiens
sont désormais des pièces de musée
puisqu'on ne les fabrique plus comme dit
léo ferré avec le temps va tout s'en va
un jour peut-être qu'il n'y aura même
plus de pêcheurs et par voie de
conséquence même plus de pointu en
attendant le jour de la saint pierre à
saint tropez les pointus on les fait
brûler c'est la tradition mais moi j'ai
vu est un jeune j'habitais le boire
envolé le chemin des filets avec avec
c'était un symbole la fin d'une vieille
que son envoyé voilà un bateau qui brûle
c'est un peu triste mais c'est beau très
beau et tellement plus émouvant qu'un
yacht qui accostent ainsi se termine
cette édition je vous en rappelle les
principaux titres après l'éclatante
victoire sur l'allemagne hier soir les
futurs adversaires de la france en
demi-finale ont regagné en héros leur
base à vittel alors que zagreb a fêté
toute la nuit cette victoire historique
je n'ai juste pas invité du club de la
presse d'europe affirme ça va mieux
bilan positif de son gouvernement une
politique lisible dit-il dans un instant
la météo patrice drevet demain matin
dans les quatre vérités à 7h50 marie
pierre farkas recevra à munich via
secrétaire générale du snes à 20h vous
retrouverez daniel bilalian je vous
remercie de votre attention
excellente fin de soirée sur france 2
là